us now from central London is the
Egyptian ambassador to the UK NASA
caramel thanks very much indeed for
talking to us how concerned are you that
there have been two attacks in two days
on tourists in Egypt well on one hand of
course we are concerned I mean what
happened in Cairo and hurghada but also
what happened in Paris and Philadelphia
we can see a surge in people being
recruited by this ideology of hate
trying to do harm all over the world but
at the other on the other side were
quite satisfied when it comes to the
prompt reaction of the security forces
and service in Egypt both those attack
were foiled the police intervened
promptly killing the assailant or
arresting them none has been able to to
escape so which means that we have a
plan and that we are doing our best
secure everyone in tourist sites and
everywhere else in the country you
mentioned Paris in Philadelphia Islamic
state has claimed responsibility for the
attack in Giza near the pyramids however
we haven't had any claim of
responsibility from this latest attack
in hurghada but reports suggest that the
attackers had an Islamic state flag do
you believe that they were acting in the
name of Islamic state in attack I can't
claim I have information but from what
we've seen in Egypt and in Paris and in
Philadelphia it seems that recruiting by
dash on the internet lone Wolf's here
and they're all over the world are
taking action against us as human beings
as humankind so I think we have to come
together and face this threat it is a
collective threat not only to Egypt or
to the rest of the world how safe is
Egypt for tourists well Egypt is as safe
as any other major
country order or city in the world I
mean we've seen incident all over Europe
we've seen in the US and of course we've
seen those two incidents in Egypt the
authority in Egypt has proved that they
have the capability and they have they
are ready and the readiness is there so
it is not more or less safe than any
other destination in the world let's
look at the Red Sea resource then
because of course her garden not so far
from Sharm el-sheikh it was from Sharm
el-sheikh that that Russian jet took off
and was later downed how worried are you
about that bit of coastline how hard is
it to police a coastline like that
actually those two coastal city are the
best garden not only in Egypt but maybe
in the world and that's not my way of
describing it but actually Egyptian
British Authority tends to believe the
same and that's why your travel advisory
still encouraging people to go to
hurghada and even Sharma chef is being
portrayed as a safe destination the
issue was with the airport and we are
working with the British authority to
implement a joint action plan and we
have hired a renowned British security
adviser control risk to improve security
at Sharma chef airport so from outside
expertise those city are being viewed
and perceived as quite safe how
concerned are you about Islamic state
gaining ground gaining influence gaining
power within Egypt I mean getting ground
gaining power that's absolutely out of
context what's happening in Egypt is
happening as i said in france in other
countries where you have one two or
three
a number of people who might be lured by
this ideology of hate and and and and
and plan to take action I mean like the
one we've seen in hurghada yesterday but
Egypt has made a choice and a choice is
clear the overall majority of the
Egyptian have voted for a secular state
and have understood the pattern of this
hit a geology of it ok well now so como
Egyptian ambassador to the UK thanks
very much in taking your time this
afternoon thank you